we're going to start with the system at
701 I want to play this for you and then
we're going to talk about it let's start
there
two which prevented me from posting
it's got a strike no big deal
the next day
met up took me down deleted my Facebook
and my Instagram
um the Press came out at exactly the
same time in sync saying that I'm a
misogynistic dangerous person that I'm
harmful that I am the reason that the
world is not a perfect place world
hunger you name it all my fault
attacked me across all of this and I
thought okay let me film a message that
I can get out on my YouTube my final
message which I don't know if you guys
have seen I ended up putting on
freetopg.com let me film my final
message explaining how this is unfair
and unjust we filmed it we produced it
we got it all edited within 12 hours had
to tell ready to go but we couldn't post
it because the YouTube straight so we're
waiting for the YouTube strike to expire
a few hours before the YouTube strike
expires guess what happened
they Banned Me from YouTube
then they Banned Me from Discord then
they banned me for Airbnb Airbnb from
stripe they bet I can't even remember it
was just emails coming in faster than
you could believe
oh no no the Matrix presses a button my
friend and every app on your phone stops
working Uber
you name it Uber stop you name it wait
you can't use Uber well I can use Uber
you just start a new account right but
yeah oh sorry Uber okay but uh but your
main account on Uber was taken they take
everything and everything everyone made
an effort all at once all at once every
single one of them just goes no delete
delete delete delete and I come at you
and they come at you everything that's
right that payment process UK based
Banks as well High Street Banks
that I can name Santander HSBC Barclays
Etc all at the same time oh no sorry the
change we've decided because blah blah
some [ __ ] some let her close your
accounts so they take all your banking
they take your payment processing take
all your social media presence they take
your Discord they take your Skype they
take all your accounts your ability to
communicate with people and then they
lie about you in the press okay and then
so there you have it there you have it
that's how it goes by the way he's not
lying there's he has no reason by the
way to lie about any of this information
he knows damn well everyone's fact
checking everything that he says at this
point but that's how it works that
should [ __ ] scare everybody you
should be terrified watching that this
is a guy who just has an opinion he
doesn't have a record he's not a
criminal
he's not he hasn't he's just a guy out
there saying stuff words
why why a coordinated attack so I want
you to pay attention to how this
happened to him because the fact that
this hit places like Airbnb the fact
that this play hit things like uber your
bank accounts for what
that goes to show you that somebody at
the top presses a button and it's just
like all the Christmas tree lights go on
and all of a sudden you're just shut out
so the point is not to remove you from
YouTube or to remove you from social
media that's not the point the point is
to terrify your ass
to put you into a mode where you are
terrified to speak your mind so they can
then sit in their little office and
Silicon Valley be being Pat in the back
by the way by big government oftentimes
government and social media go hand in
hand in this country and God knows
what's going on in other countries let
me speak for this one hand in hand that
coordinated messaging comes right from
the top down
they sit and they watch and they say huh
did he learn his lesson
that is the goal did you learn your
lesson did you shut up did you stop
saying what you were going to say
because it was dangerous to to what they
want to achieve that is the goal it's
not it's about striking fear into people
because here's the thing if they can
strike fear into that guy what chance do
you have
you don't have as many followers as him
you don't have as much money as him you
don't have as much power and influence
as him I certainly don't not today
you you certainly don't I don't know
who's listening to this maybe somebody
out there is I don't know but this guy's
pretty pretty influential In This Moment
so if they can strike fear into him and
shut him up you don't have a chance
that is how it works do you remember
go back and look at covid that the week
that I showed up on The View the week I
showed up naive as I was and I went and
I was going to share my story about why
I didn't get the vaccine and why I felt
that mandating an experimental drug for
the population was outrageous that was
my perspective I show up and what did it
get called misinformation go look at the
news that week that word was everywhere
that word was you think that word just
popped out of Sunny hosten's mouth no
honey no it didn't
that was a coordinated message that came
from the top because they had to make
everyone who was saying something
different look stupid look wrong and
look dangerous they had to scare you
much like they tried to scare me off
that show oh let's shut down Jed and
then people won't come on here and say
that
screw you man I was gonna say my piece
no matter what and that should be your
attitude when you hear this stuff you
have to resist this stuff
this guy is resisting it this guy is
saying you thought you were going to
shut me up well you didn't because
people still look people still want to
talk to him
he's over at Rumble now he's saying
we're going to get to that that he's got
more views going on over there than he
ever had on YouTube because there is a
Marketplace for people who are tired of
this [ __ ] this is not about left or
right by the way some of it is but a lot
of it is about people who care about
Free Speech a lot of it is about people
who want to step up and say I don't
agree with you but I'm not willing to
live in a world where I shut you up and
then five years from now I say something
you don't like and you shut me up and
that's our new reality
so what he's doing and what he's saying
is really really important here it comes
from the top down
if you don't think if you think the
blind Administration didn't play a role
in that misinformation this information
misinformation you're nuts in the same
way that you learned that the CDC and
the teachers unions were colluding this
is all a top-down strategy this is what
he's talking about when he talks about
the system
we talk about it here all the time big
Hollywood big Tech big government boom
messaging where are the outliers let's
find them let's shut them up
refused to be silenced and you won't be
silenced that is the message pay
attention to what he's doing if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
foreign
[Music]